The joe rogan experience,
or maybe she was a psychic and she predicted her own demise.
Maybe she knew her timeline was raises a question.
What's,
what,
what's the way you'd want to die?
Uh,
I'd want to die with a mask on and an orgy.
Glad you brought that out because it's reminds me of a story.
I asked variance a story that Brian was telling me yesterday that was so good.
I said,
stop talking.
Stop talking and telling me this tomorrow.
Well,
you know,
little can't tell the names involved.
I can't tell the names.
There was a celebrity of them all,
but it's a very significant celebrity.
When we were growing up,
this celebrity was a big star.
Yes.
And,
and uh,
I'll tell you to say whether or not they were a part of a no,
we cannot.
No,
I cannot say anything else.
Telly Savalas no,
no,
no.
But,
um,
but,
uh,
a handsome young man,
can you say,
we reserve a music star,
a movie still not allowed to say anything.
He said he was a celebrity.
He was a celebrity,
let's put it that way.
And,
and,
um,
and the reason I only say things cause you know,
it was a private thing.
I mean I admire the guy actually I have for doing what he did,
but,
okay.
So tell us what happened.
Well,
you know,
in life I was just many,
many moons ago,
many,
uh,
at least I think six years ago or something.
And,
um,
I was single.
Um,
and I,
I,
uh,
there are things certain guys want to do,
you know,
you want to like,
I always say this,
you go,
you want to stop a crime,
do you want to kill somebody with a sword?
You want to fucking,
you know,
uh,
and then you want to bang six girls at the same time.
I mean,
that's,
that's one of my goals.
Six.
Well,
I'm driving penis.
Do you have,
and I do well,
and I'll show you,
I'll show you after the story.
Uh,
but I,
I'm uh,
I'm driving to Venice.
I get a call from a girl I used to bang,
who was a for Riek wonderful.
I mean a real Vegas pro.
So,
uh,
she gives me a call and uh,
she goes,
what are you doing?
And I go,
I driving a vintage.
She goes,
she goes,
get your ass up to this hotel.
And it was,
it was,
let's just call it the shirt and she was getting your ass,
the Sheridan right now we got,
we got six girls and only two Cox.
We need you now.
So I'm like,
ah.
I'm like,
Nah,
I fucking,
I got an audition for Sydney Pollack next day.
Fluxing which I did.
Right.
And I'm like,
I Jackson Pollock's brother.
Yes it is.
Yes.
The painter and I got,
I got,
I gotta go,
I gotta go to fucking,
I can't do,
that's probably,
hey,
I can't,
you know,
I'm going on my way to,
to vent now.
All you,
the only thing you can do in that situation is just faint.
Otherwise just faint,
faint,
Bica or,
or die there or pull over and sleep and wake up in the morning because any other
movement is going to bring you toward six hot girls.
Cause I knew the kind of grocery,
Huh?
With I'm now,
I'm gone.
You mean there's a fucking,
there's a back end suite and the Sharon,
I feel you tell the story before you even go any further,
you decided to tell this story recently at the UCB.
I told the story at the UCB podcast and it was interesting because they're all
very nice group and very funny and talented group of people,
but they are,
they're not,
they probably not live the kind of sexual deviancy that I have gone through,
you know?
And so I just feel that they just seem like wholesome good people,
you know,
that don't have just this deep dark matter living inside there.
And so I got up and told his story that I'm about to tell you guys about
essentially my experience in a fucking orgy.
Uh,
and then what made you want to tell this?
I,
I fucking want to tell the truth about who I really am.
I just felt like I just felt like going up and going and he's a really cute
stories.
You guys.
Uh,
now let me tell you what,
I'll fucking Devion.
I really am.
I mean,
you know,
when you didn't think there were cute stories.
I mean,
I didn't really,
I didn't listen to that hard but,
but I know that people involved,
they're funny.
I mean a lot of moisture.
This,
the standard Kong moisture is funny as shit.
He's funny.
He's got a great sense of humor and the other guys,
I haven't seen a lot of their work,
but it used to be,
it puts out some pretty bad ass comics.
I mean,
it's funny,
funny fucking people like Amy Poehler came out of there and great people.
And so they're telling their stories and for whatever reason you decided to take
it down per lane.
Tell a story that you never even told me.
I've never told anybody because you know,
I mean it's just,
it's just like,
I was like,
I want to tell something that's a little outrageous because I don't want any
secrets in my fucking life.
I just want to,
I just want to be fucking out there and I don't give a fuck.
I don't care what really care what other people think.
I care what my friends think.
You know,
my friends all know exactly who the fuck I am.
All my friends know who I was.
So much freedom in that.
But there's always freedom and that I can't,
I'm not good at keeping a facade up.
So I tell this story.
So,
so I'm driving and I go,
I hang on my first impulse,
I can't do what I can do it.
Now.
I had listened,
there was this thing where you might've told me,
Joe,
we were talking about a woman who was dying of cancer and they said,
if you could do it all over again,
what would you do?
And she said,
I wouldn't do anything because it made sense.
And I,
I was thinking about that when I got this phone call.
I was thinking,
you know,
I wanna I want to do,
you gotta live your life sometimes and you've got to have experiences and you've
got to fucking do something that kind of shocks and astonishes yourself.
And by the way,
you don't know a guy out there who wouldn't want to fuck six girls at the same
time.
So I hear that.
But I'm driving and I,
my first info,
Nah,
I gotta go get it.
I've got to study my audition.
I got an audition tomorrow,
but now I'm thinking,
holy fuck.
And he's going,
well,
you know what I'll do?
I'm going to drive.
If I see a seven 11 I'll stop and get condoms.
It doesn't mean I'm going there.
I'm not trying to him my,
but I'm going to stop and maybe if I get another call,
no good.
Some other,
oh look,
a seven 11 I'm going to pull up,
but I'm definitely not going in this chair it and there's no way I blow off.
And I go,
Oh,
you guys don't have any condoms.
Buy Condoms.
Phone rings again.
Where the fuck are you?
So while this was going on,
you're basically like a junkie that someone's saying,
come on,
let's do some blow.
I'm not basically like a junkie.
I am a junkie.
All right.
It is.
But that feeling when you're about to do something really deviant is junky.
Junky my heart and my heart's beating fast and I'm getting,
and I can't get it out of my mind.
I keep going back to it.
I keep trying to put it out in my mind and I'm a loser and man,
I'm losing the battle.
I'm getting pulled under.
They're adding more and more weight and I'm trying to keep up.
I got my,
I'm like,
okay,
I can't go under water.
I keep doing this.
I'm treading water,
but they're just adding weights to my legs with the imagery.
I'm thinking about these girls.
Long story short,
I go,
fuck it.
I find myself at the Sheraton.
I go up to the suite,
I get met at the door by my girl.
She's wearing a mask.
She gives me a porcelain doll mask to put on.
So I go,
oh.
And then she gives me a strip of paper with the rules of the game,
which is that this is a birthday girl and my,
um,
and I am fucking,
the only rule is I can't hit or spit.
I'm like,
okay,
I wasn't planning on hitting and spitting these girls.
I'm going to fuck them.
Whoa,
whoa.
Is this stuff written down?
[inaudible] printed is written,
typed,
very neat strip of paper.
Wow.
So this is well organized.
So everyone has a a sheet.
I walk in,
I walk in and I go and I see fucking four of the hottest girls I've ever seen.
One girl's getting banged on the bed by some muscular dude,
and then there's a dude who's kind of just standing off to the side not doing
anything with like a shaved jazz.
And I'm like,
God,
I don't like that guy.
He's weird.
He's getting fucking looks all bloated.
He's just like been lifting a lot of ways and never did a sport in his life.
I'm like,
whatever.
Shaved chests,
orange,
the shape and some weird mask.
I was like,
all right.
Then I looked at myself,
everyone's naked dude.
Yeah.
And guess what?
She goes,
you've got to take your clothes off right now.
You'd have to get no,
no clothes.
So she starts peeling my pants off.
She gets on her knees and starts to work me.
And as I'm getting work by my,
my old girlfriend,
I got this porcelain doll mascot.
I look in the mirror and I look at my fucking doll mass and I go,
ah,
there's the first thought.
Literally not that on my Dick is getting sucked.
I go,
that's weird.
My fucking dumb ass cause is what is my legs?
I gotta Start Tanning Roast.
I'm like,
I'm fucking gross.
And this one girl goes,
yeah,
you,
you at the white skin.
And that doll masking a hard on.
That's not creepy.
I'm like,
oh Yay,
whatever.
So this,
this really hot girl who turns out to be the birthday girl who happens to be the
celebrities wife,
she gets down on her knees and I get pushed over to her and now I'm getting
worked by her.
But the thing is,
she's really fucking good at it.
And I go,
um,
I'm going to go,
I'm not a porn star.
I when a girl is hot as moment with a mask on and I'm totally anonymous with a
mask on my face,
I'm fucking gonna come.
And plus I got to come cause I got an audition tomorrow.
I want in and out.
So I'm like,
oh.
And I go,
I'm going to fucking,
he keep doing it.
I'm gonna come and the guy and I hear you're going to come.
And I look over and it's a guy,
I'm like,
I think I recognize that guy.
I know him from somewhere,
but whatever.
He goes,
whole lot shoe and a video camera comes out and it's right on the girl.
And I'm like,
Oh really?
All right.
I guess this was like the Duke Porn.
Ooh,
my knees lock up and whew.
Which by the way,
I never locked their mouth or face where in her mouth.
My friend.
Yeah.
And the husband filming this,
he films that and uh,
yeah.
And then I hope I don't ever have to do a Disney show cause I'm fucked.
Fucked.
This is all fiction is,
is all fiction.
But this is,
this is part of the,
this is part of my fictional story that I'm doing on stage one man show.
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah.
So now,
now,
um,
now I,
uh,
by the way,
I'm speaking,
this actually happened to a friend and I'm speaking and telling you,
I'm telling the story.
How can we've got enough disclaimers?
Yeah.
I was just telling her like three of them that has happened to my friend and,
and so,
uh,
so now I go,
oh shit.
I just lost it.
Good.
I can get the fuck outta here.
Cause this is a freak show and I don't belong here.
And I,
you know,
I got an orange guy in the corner with,
have a horn on and another dude banging the girl on a bed and I got,
I got,
I'm like,
I get it the fuck Outta here,
but you know what?
I had an experience.
I'm going to go and I,
I can go make my Sydney Pollack,
uh,
audition.
So I'm putting on my pants and I'm about to leave.
I'm sneaking out and all of a sudden this 10 with a mass comes up and she goes,
you're not going to fuck me.
And I go,
uh,
oh.
I mean,
I,
I was going to go,
I have an I d
say it,
I'll just buy it.
Even know want her to know I was smacked her.
I'm like,
she goes,
you're not gonna find me.
And she turns around and I go,
I mean,
I don't want to be rude.
Maybe I should fuck you.
So next thing I know my parents are coming off and you know,
that's it now.
Now,
now I'm in the belly of the beast now and I'm just seeing fucking read and I'm
just going crazy.
I login and they're like,
man,
this guy's out rate.
I was appalling.
My energy level noises,
I gave it up.
I know at this point I'm like,
I'm fucking going.
Now you know what the other people grunting or is everyone kind of B,
they were kind of done
for a second.
I'm going in for seconds and everybody else quit.
They kind of quit and the girls to not athletic,
lucky not to be a dick,
but my,
my dig was mover then weren't doing so well,
so I'm just fucking going crazy.
I'm like,
this is,
look at the shit.
I,
we're really all go,
oh yeah,
I'll switch.
Oh,
why not?
Hey,
free country,
whatever.
Fuck you America.
And I'm going nuts.
And now I fucking,
uh,
get to a point where,
um,
uh,
I'm,
I'm now the girl who's the burden.
The girl goes,
I want some of this.
And she says,
don't use them up to the girl that I'm going crazy on.
She pushes,
she,
she pushes me down on the bed,
she gets on top of me.
So as I'm being taken care of by this beautiful girl,
now I'm being worked on my back and trying my hardest not to lose it.
Um,
cause she's so beautiful.
And so,
uh,
all of a sudden at this point,
the celebrity who now I now recognize cause he's drunk and the mask is crooked
on his face.
So it's like,
I'm like,
I see your face.
All right,
well they are,
they don't.
And he goes,
I want to get it.
I want to get,
let me get,
let me,
let me get you,
you know he wants a sandwich or he wants to go in,
in south.
So he wants to,
while she's on top of you,
he wants us to get in and around.
Yes.
Oh,
she turns to him and she was going touch.
There's no way around that.
The whole thing's a disaster.
Right?
So she looks back and she goes,
she says to him,
she goes,
mmm.
Something like,
you know,
she has this like silent kind of like language.
Like,
no,
I don't want to do that.
And I know too,
that man,
man.
And he's like,
come on it.
And there's a debate going on.
So finally she's like,
she hits back to me and we,
by the way,
we're connected.
We're connected.
We're making love at this point.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yours,
your Dick's in her vagina and his Dick in her butt hole.
He tries,
but he can't get it.
How many times his Dick Touch yours.
Never buy that.
If it did,
and if it did,
it doesn't matter,
because I wouldn't have felt that anyway.
I don't care.
I'm not squeamish there.
I said it really well.
I don't know.
I'm,
I'm doing it.
This girl,
I'm going to this girl.
Well,
okay,
so he's got a fungus on his balls off.
I wasn't even thinking,
dude.
I was just like,
this is,
this is an experience I'm already done.
I'm already fucked.
So,
so he can't get up.
And she,
and he goes,
ah.
He goes,
oh,
what the fuck?
I can't get in.
And she turns around and goes,
what?
The,
don't fucking play me.
I told her I didn't want to do it.
And they start having a fight about not being able to get on her ass as I'm
having sex with her and they're having a fight.
And I'm thinking to myself,
I look around and I'm like,
that's,
this is the beginning of the end and this relationship,
this is a weird thing to have a fight about a,
there's another issue that,
you know,
you're,
you're fucking Nigga.
That's all right.
Whatever.
I get that.
But there's swingers,
so,
so he can't get in.
They have this fight and then he kind of storms off and she kind of goes back to
me and we do our thing.
And so,
uh,
so now I can't believe this is like the most popular podcasts and I'm,
there goes my reputation by the way.
And so now it comes time for me to,
she wants me to finish it off in a porn fashion,
which would be again in her mouth.
And so I go,
okay,
and so now we're going to do the whole money shot thing.
And I just,
it's been a long time and I just lose it,
you know,
right away again.
And as I'm,
you know,
coming,
uh,
I,
I see Mr celebrity come running around with a camera and he comes around,
he goes,
oh,
what the fuck?
Hey,
why did you let him call him so fast?
I wanted to film it.
And she goes,
what am I supposed to stick my dick in his fucking up the stick my finger in his
dick?
Don't be an asshole.
I don't have any control of it.
And they,
now they get an argument about that.
And as their argument,
I'm like,
I thank you so much.
I throw on my fucking man,
I run the fuck out of there and okay,
I need to know who is by the way,
then they got divorced.
Have you ever seen that guy since then?
Oh No.
That would get the mind,
my lucky guess.
No,
no,
no.
I gotta I gotta I gotta save some anyway.
I wasn't there by the way.
That story that doesn't belong to me.
That's a,
that's a friend of mine story.
But I was smooth stream has apparently died.
You noticed what happened?
Is it us,
US Easter nine to the stories people tuned in the truck.
Is it just Ustream crashed?
Yeah.
Sorry.
Well we're still broadcasting.
Yes.
You have to download it from my too and sung the,
and the best part.
So,
um,
you've never had a situation like this ever again.
This was let's like one of those stories that you hear about like that's like a
Hollywood story I've had,
I've had those experiences more than one.
Yeah.
How many times he had been in the same room with another guy,
with a girl.
How many times,
I mean,
I don't want to get too detailed,
but when I was single in La and um,
and,
and you know,
with,
with a house and no worries and that was young guy why I did that kind of stuff.
I'm all the time.
I mean I didn't have,
I wasn't a swinger,
I didn't go to orgies,
I didn't organize anything.
But I've,
I was pretty good at getting,
I think my friends until I was pretty good at getting a group of great open
minded girls together and hoggin off.
It's a funny thing to talk about though,
isn't it?
It's a funny thing to talk about because when you,
when you start saying,
you know,
banged all these girls,
I bang this girl by now you open yourself up to people getting angry.
I don't care.
I know you don't.
I mean I don't,
I don't because,
because I do anything wrong.
I didn't do anything wrong and,
and I,
and I would do it again and I had a blast.
I have fucking blast and it's true.
And it turned me on is that turned me on.
You want to turn me on you,
you know,
you throw a bunch of like six really cool girls in a room and they're all like,
we want to fuck you.
[inaudible] that turns me on.
Yeah,
it turns me off.
Gets me going.
Sorry.
But no,
it's a crime.
But yeah,
I'm down.
Isn't it funny though,
that you,
you think about this,
like the way people describe it,
like this is a fucked up thing to talk about.
You know,
the tricky thing,
yeah,
it's a,
it's taboo because I,
when I was telling the story of UCB,
it was actually kind of an experiment.
I was like,
I want to see what happens to this audience.
When I tell a real story about something that most people would never admit to
because it makes you look to a lot of people bad.
It may or it makes you look like a pervert,
but I don't believe in that shit.
I don't buy it and anybody knows me knows.
I'm just not hung up on that stuff.
I'm really not.
And,
uh,
and I wouldn't change that experience for the fucking world.
What's that guy's name?
Vincent Gallo is what his name is,
who they want to do that movie brown butter.
We're Chloe and she still has a career and she blew him in the movie the movie
and in the scene she actually sucks his dick and he keeps,
especially women when,
uh,
what I notice about,
um,
I told that story,
there are a lot of women in the,
and UCB women were really open when women were really like,
found like I had a couple women say hi,
I found that story really honest and refreshing.
And,
and,
and how do you end it?
What do you say?
It was a slippery slope once you,
like if somebody calls you about an orgy,
if you don't turn around and drive home immediately and throw handcuffs on
yourself,
anything else is a slippery slope and you're going down that slope.
If you're a guy like me.
So you got to fucking,
you know,
and that's,
and,
and you know that story about getting a call,
like that is what a lot of us deal with on a day to day basis with our
addictions.
Whether it's,
I'm trying to stop smoking,
I'm trying to stop drinking,
I'm trying to stop fucking watching porn all day,
whatever it is.
People have these addictions trying to stop meth.
I'm trying to stop heroin.
These,
it's the same addiction,
man.
It's the same.
It's the same impulse.
And,
and so just to suggest that I don't have some of that in me and that I in the
past haven't acted on,
that is dishonest.
And by the way,
his concern is suggesting I'm not human.
Fuck you.
If you've got a judgment on that,
I thought it was awesome.
And you know,
and that's how it is.